wadn't you to write or give up on a
screenplay that it's such a good
question because I'm not sure you should
ever give up on a screenplay but at the
same time there's the point where you
should shelve it for a while and until
you figure out what's wrong with it and
I have a bunch of scripts that I fact
this the spec script that I'm working on
now is a script that got shelved because
I couldn't figure it out and it just it
wasn't working and I put it on the shelf
and went on to do other things I do this
thing called cross-training because when
I'm not writing one thing I'm writing
something else so often if I take the
screenplay that I can't figure out the
answers to put it on the shelf and write
some other things
I will then learn something that helps
me solve the problems for that
screenplay and so it's like there's I
have scripts that that have been on the
Shelf forever because I still haven't
figured it out other scripts that go on
the shelf I read a couple of scripts and
I figure out what the problem is but
giving up on a screenplay I don't know
there's always to me there's always
something of me in every screenplay so
it's it's you know do I want to give up
on my arm no it's like you know I still
my arm I want to go back and figure out
why my art what's going on with my arm
and make it work again this gets to
Roman Polanski's the tenant what right
does my head have to call itself me but
yeah I don't think you should ever give
up on the screenplay you should shelve
it though for a while and go on to
something else I think too often people
don't put their script aside and so what
they're doing is they don't know the
solution to the problem and they they
often just make it worse by rewriting
and rewriting without knowing how to get
out of it not knowing the solution to
the problem where if you put it aside it
allows you fresh eyes your mind goes off
if you're trying to remember a line to
some movie the best way to remember it
is try not to remember it so you know
trivia so if you're trying to figure out
the solution to a screenplay problem the
best thing to do is not try to figure
out how to solve it but go on to
something else and then you'll figure
out the solution sometime and you know
the script I'm working on right now is
was a script that was originally
designed as a movie for Orion Pictures
at a producer who had to deal with the
Ryan Pictures
had this grip that I pitched that he
said would go to treatment with the
treatment on the script and then Orion
Pictures went bankrupt the story of my
life and the the script now that the
producer said well we can't do it for
that budget but we can do it on a
smaller budget so now take this script
that was a big script and turn it into a
small script and it didn't work that way
so the film never got made I bought the
rights back and it's been sitting on my
shelf as I've been waiting to figure out
how to turn it now in today's world into
a movie that's the bigger budget version
and it's it was it's like a North by
Northwest chase movie which at some
point in time got shrunk down to no
chase it just did not work but but that
trying to figure out the solution to
that problem took me a while so it took
me the decade of not thinking about it
other other scripts I have a script
about a reincarnated girl who totally
rolled girl whose was a murder victim in
her past life and then she suddenly just
her past like bleeds through she's gonna
track down the killer and the problem
was there was only one suspect in the
script and it's like so when we over she
finds a guy she kills him and I that
wouldn't work so I came up with other
suspects that didn't work and that's
went back on the shelf until I figured
out one of the characters from her past
life would grow older and as the older
character could become a suspect now and
then we would reveal that the reason why
he's hanging around her and her pet in
her current version of her that's a
little girl is because he can sense that
it's this person he knew before and I
thought that could be a real creepy
twist thing but before it was just
suspect number 27 that I made up but by
finding that by putting it on the shelf
and coming up with that it became a much
better script and a deeper script and it
goes into maybe how can we sense other
people from our past lives you know it's
got a cool idea that's
you